joining us
hello everybody thank you for joining us
for the seminar today i'm charlie
clifford and i'm going to be discussing
rodent health surveillance
innovation driving changes
i work for a company charles river
we sell laboratory rodents
and we also
run a commercial diagnostic lab so we do
the monitoring not only for our own
animals but quite a bit of outside
monitoring for externally submitted
animals as well
and i work to
develop our own internal health
monitoring programs to be sure that we
know what's in our colonies we're not
missing anything
that sort of thing we can't afford to
have false positives or false negatives
and then i also work with a lot of our
external clients trying to help them
improve or optimize their own health
surveillance programs
i'm sure everybody is very familiar with
the problems that are incumbent on
health surveillance programs today or
inherent to them
as we make more and more precise
measurements in science
we find that there's an increasing need
for microbiologic stability
let me just stop for a moment here and
say if you have questions as we go
through please type them in
and if possible i'll answer some as we
go
but i'll get to any others at the end so
please remember to enter your questions
so there is a need for increasing
microbiologic stability of the animals
that we use
some people are looking at the
microbiome
and certainly those animals need to be
microbiologically stable
also
we're using a lot of animals with
immune deficiencies both to study the
immune system and to grow
human tumors or other tissue components
these have increasingly more and more
severe immune deficiencies such as the
nsg mouse
in the face of this need for
microbiological microbiologic stability
though
there are some subclinical infections
that remain quite common then i'll touch
on those
one of the reasons i think they stay so
common
is that uh
it's the
negative side of using
individually ventilated caging
uh
individually ventilated cages are used
to prevent infections from going from
one cage to another and they work very
well but they're not perfect and so it's
still possible that one or a few cages
on iraq could have some sort of
infection or another and that makes
health monitoring or hm very difficult
sometimes even infections could get into
one or a couple cages and then just die
out
maybe your sentinel gets positive and by
then the infection has died out on the
rest of the rack
and
the way that everybody uses to monitor
these individually ventilated cages
there's a soiled vetting system and
we'll talk a little more about that and
although it it works okay much of the
time it does have some significant
limitations that i think everybody needs
to recognize and then finally everybody
is working in an environment of
increased economic constraints
everybody wants to save money everybody
wants to get more for the money they're
spending and that's just the reality
and
that has a downside but it also has the
good side of continually pushing us to
try to
improve
so there are some solutions to some of
these obviously and that's what i'm
going to be talking about today there
have been some improvements in serology
two of them i i think are uh
that miniaturization of the assays has a
permitted increased uh
catholic testing that can be done with
very small amounts of blood
and
that allows us to take a tiny bit of
blood from an animal without having to
kill the animal just to see what it had
when it was alive
now one of the ways that we do this now
is what's called dried blood spot
sampling where a tiny spot of blood is
just put onto a filter card and then
that can just be sent in the mail for
testing
also pcr is used more and more and has
been enhanced to work now we can just
test animals directly coming into a
quarantine facility
to see
what
active infections they might have that
could pose a threat to the other animals
in the facility
and by testing these directly without
having to use sentinels
it can accelerate the whole process you
can get perhaps three or four times as
many animals through quarantine as you
could previously
and finally sensitivity of pcr has been
developed to the point that we can just
sample dust in the animals of space
without even having to sample the
animals at all so we can just look at
the dust and we can tell what infections
are present in the animals
and finally
i think people are increasingly
recognizing that quality control or
health monitoring is just a form of
quality control to see if the animals
meet your specifications it's not some
sort of vague take a look at them see
what else they might have is to see if
they have a very specific list of agents
and by doing it that way we can design
tests for each of those agents and then
you can just ship samples you don't even
have to ship animals at all so we'll go
through each of these
so i mentioned that there are some
infections that are still common in mice
and we may have an international
participation today and these are some
numbers from around
in europe the numbers i've seen are very
similar
but essentially laboratory mice
tend to have the same infections
everywhere
they have norovirus
the various parvo viruses mouse
hepatitis virus
epizootic diarrhea of infant mice medium
and tmev or tyler's murine
encephalomyelitis virus
i did some compilation of numbers of
just coming through our lips these are
all the samples that have come through
our lab in the last several years it's
about 800 000 samples all together and a
good prevalence in quotes because it's
not really
prevalent says and this is the percent
of animals in the bavarian that have the
infections but
you know the things that we see at a
very high number those are common and
the things that we don't see if we
haven't seen them in 800 000 samples
they're really really rare so what
should you worry about what's most
likely to get into your facility what's
the stuff that's common the same things
that are getting into other people's
facilities and so you have to take these
numbers with a grain of salt
we see a lot of norovirus we see quite a
bit of the parvo viruses mpv and mpm mdm
but even though only about one percent
of the samples that come through our lab
are positive
if you get out and you ask people at
different institutions whether
they
have it at their facility
it turns out that probably 40 percent or
more
are
positive for that
so it's a very high number of the
institutions have at least a little bit
of paraviruses
and then
the viruses we monitored by serology
mfia
and
helicobacter pastoral and pneumotropica
furmites and 10 worms those are numbers
that we produced by testing by pcr so
it's a little bit different um just have
to keep in mind those are the numbers
we're finding
but those are the things that are common
so how do people check for these
well in north america at least in most
research facilities probably the most
common way to house mice are in these
individually ventilated cages
and
since something can be present in
infection could be present in those it
may be only one percent at prevalence
you you really can't sample enough
animals randomly to have a good idea if
there's anything there or not so what
everybody does is they use soiled
bedding sentinels and the usual scenario
for this is there will be one cage of
two mice per side of the rack and one
side of the rack might have 80 cages so
one cage of sentinels for up to 80 cages
of mice uh the research mice
every week when the bedding in the cages
gets changed the 80 even 100 cages
sometimes
about 5 ml of bedding once a week gets
moved into the sentinel cage that's
about a teaspoon of bedding
the cage is generally changed to the
hood
the soiled bedding gets put in either
into a paper bag as i've heard some
places or just into what will be the
sentinel cage and then at the end of the
day
the sentinels get that bedding if
there's too much bedding they may only
get some of it and hopefully it gets
mixed up
so there's a lot of dilution there if
only one of the cages had any infectious
material in it
so what do we assume you know we're
assuming some things are happening
during the monitoring period the
monitoring period is usually three
months
we're assuming that whatever they have
is going to be present in the feces and
gets transferred into the soiled bedding
we're assuming that the people doing the
transfer are actually collecting some
fecal pellets and not the cleanest
looking bedding you know and maybe we
get some things that could be shed in
the urine but not much is shed in the
urine we assume that the sentinel
actually gets an infectious dose
into its cage and remember for some
things it takes a pretty good dose parbo
viruses for example a few viral
particles are not likely to cause an
infection so we're assuming though that
the sentinel cage will actually get an
infectious dose of the virus
we're assuming
that whatever it is we're trying to
transfer doesn't just dry out and die
before it actually gets to to be exposed
to the sentinel and we know for
helicobacter it can die maybe in half an
hour or so so we're kind of working
against ourselves because we're assuming
that whatever we're transferring
wouldn't dry out
we're assuming that even if there are
only a couple fecal pellets that are
infectious in that entire sentinel cage
the fentanyl is going to find that
particular fecal pellet and infect
itself
and and i think it works pretty well
it's not bad but we're assuming that
happens
and really it does work much of the time
we with all those assumptions you can
see why it doesn't work all the time but
it works pretty well much of the time
but it does have some limitations so if
we take that previous chart or graph or
table rather and we look at what
actually gets transferred very reliably
by soiled bedding
versus what only gets transferred
sometimes or really very poorly we can
see that most of the viruses get
transferred pretty well
we know norovirus doesn't always get
transferred but obviously it does pretty
well where we wouldn't be seeing 40
percent of the animals
the samples that come through our lab be
positive for it but we know sometimes
it's not
helicobacter tends to dry out furmites
may not be present in the soil bedding
ten worms some of the pinworms are not
even uh present in fecal pellets so
those don't get transferred very well
so
the conclusion for the sentinels are
that it can be successful for some
common infections and sometimes it finds
others you know sometimes you can find
helicobacter sometimes you can find
pinworms or fermites even but
not so often
still
if you're using soil bedding sentinels
over a long period of time sooner or
later you're likely to find what's there
and if you're using it across your
entire facility
you probably have a pretty good idea of
what shows up now and again in your
facility
but it's harder to know but on a single
rack at a given time because what
because sentinels are just a little more
fuzzy they're not as focused but until
recently this has been the most best
method available
so let's look at what we have for
diagnostics pretty briefly
serology
is the old mainstay and it's a beautiful
thing it really is serology is great
it's inexpensive it's highly specific it
seems to be very sensitive we don't get
a lot of false positives we don't get
too many false negatives if the animals
have a good immune system
it takes about a week for an animal to
produce antibodies but after that
they're present for the life of the
animal and so that's really good uh it
doesn't matter whether a virus was in
the lung or the liver or kidney or
whatever
we know what sample to collect we don't
have to go looking for the agents
because it will always be present in the
serum and so that also is very good one
of the disadvantages is that we can only
test one animal at a time
so
but for the animal that we're testing it
really works very well
as we developed larger and larger
serology panels trying to test a single
serum sample for many different agents
and some of our biggest panels of agents
would have 20 different viruses on them
we looked at multiplexing now
multiplexing is where you run multiple
assays in a single well or subarray
so multiple assays within a single
basically a single reaction vessel and
this can be efficient because we
wouldn't need to use as much reagents we
don't need as much sample
and
if we can do more controls
then we can have better accuracy so
multiplexing actually works very well
for serology it does not work very well
for pcr and i'll talk about that later
but we did pursue multiplexing for
serology
we use what's called the uh and i think
some of our competitor labs do too and
it's widespread in human labs uh this uh
luminex multi-analyte profile or x-map
and in this
instead of putting the antigen
onto the bottom of the well in a plate
we put the antigen
on the sep
these polystyrene beads
and then
we can expose those beads to the animal
serum and see if the serum will bind to
the antigen that's bound to the beads
and then we use a
secondary antibody to to show
the beauty of it though is that we can
use different color beads
and so we can
these beads come in sets of up to 100
different colors so you can run 100
different assays in a single cocktail
type mixture and so in a 96 well plate
you can run 96 serum samples each for
100 different assays in theory
and so it really uses much less serum
and
you know is much more efficient for a
high throughput system
then what happens is those beads
go through what's like an old
fluorescent activated cell sorter where
each bead gets interrogated by two
lasers
one laser checks for the color of the
bead is it an mhv bead is it an mpv bead
is it a microplasma bead etc
and the other laser
checks for the phycoerythrin reporter
dye to see whether or not the animal's
serum bound to that particular antigen
so that one of them says it's a it's yes
this is a microplasma bead the other
laser says but did it was there anything
in the serum that bound to this bead
and so for each assay it'll check 25 to
100 beads and then the result is the
mean fluorescence index and so it gives
us an idea of the strength of reaction
and that helps also because a very
a weak positive is more likely to be a
false positive a very strong positive is
more likely to be a true positive so
that works very well
we call that the multiplex fluorometric
immunoassay or just mfia
so it's high throughput with much less
volume
we use many fewer plates whereas before
we used a complex robotic array to move
plates around from a washer or whatever
now we just use this simple setup that
you see in the
illustration here
and by having all the possibility to
have all those different beads we can
use multiple antigens for some diseases
for example mhv i think we use four
different antigens to screen for that to
be sure we don't miss any of the
variants of nhv and it also allows us to
use more controls so
if you send us something and say it's
mouth serum
we check to see whether there is mouse
immunoglobulin present and if there's no
mouse immunoglobulin present we know
either you sent us something from
another species
or maybe it was an immune deficient
muscles and didn't have any sarah and so
instead of just giving you a negative
result we say this is not a suitable
assay and it also we use tissue controls
and all of that so it's really a nice
system
also by having it much more simple fewer
things go wrong
it uses really small volumes of serum
really all we need to run this assay is
50 microliters of dilute serum
it's diluted
five-fold so all that would really
require would be about 20 microliters of
whole sarah so it's my nukes amount my
nude amounts and that's good that also
permits permits the next
advance
so because we require so little serum
do we really need you to send us
fluids you know whole serum or
which is harder to ship and the answer
of course is no and that's where we get
into the dried blood spot testing so
if you just put a spot of blood onto
this filter paper we can elute out
enough serum to run the assays without
losing sensitivity
because the blood gets to just dry on
this filter paper then you can just ship
it at room temperature so you don't need
to worry about
you know shipping the serum with all the
wet packs and styrofoam and everything
else
this is a illustration of it i got from
the cdc
it's an old technology
it's used a lot on human infants for
some of the tests where they just take a
little dot of blood from the heel of a
newborn and test that
basically you just put the
blood onto a card take a hole punch
punch that out put it into a plate soak
the serum out of that and then run that
like you would normal serum
charles river's version of it is called
the easy spot
and and so it's good because it's such
nice long established technology
you don't have to kill animals to get
enough serum uh to bleed
and with what we can elude out of there
you can rather run a wide variety of
analytes you can run some clinical
chemistries as well as
with antibody serology
so it allows survival blood collection
you can keep your sentinels for more
than one sampling period easily
you can even test some of the animals in
the colony
directly without having to use sentinels
and this can be good to try to
corroborate any positives that you've
got in the sentinels or if you're trying
to
test specific animals and then also it's
just a it's a much more convenient
lower labor way to prepare and ship the
samples
to the diagnostic laboratory so it seems
to be catching on really widely and i
think it's a and i think it's a great
thing
but
you're still only testing one animal at
a time
we
found that it uh when you
dilute it out we can get similar titers
out of the dried blood spot elliots that
we do out of the whole serum so uh the
we get just the strongest signal from
the dried blood spot as we do from the
whole serum
just which is a beautiful thing
there are some you need to pay attention
to the storage of the paper and the
humidity obviously the way it absorbs
the blood will vary a little bit with
the humidity
you don't want to put too much or too
little blood onto it
if there are extreme fluctuations in
adequate
that could allow you have to let it dry
and then
when we take the punches and we take a
couple punches from each uh
area from each circle
we like to select from some place where
it looks like it's uniformly distributed
and the blood isn't sort of piled up
into uh into one area so there's a
little more potential for variability
but we are not finding a problem
so it's a great thing it's been around
for more than 40 years but really just
now is going into rodent diagnostics
much more convenient for shipping and
but still has the sensitivity
however still it's just one animal at a
time
and it doesn't address the basic
surveillance problems with individually
ventilated cages
which is that are things getting to the
sentinels in the first place or how to
sample enough animals
and that's where we come to pcr
pcr panels have become a primary tool
for screening groups of animals directly
without the need for sentience so you
can just take samples directly from an
animal and see what they have
the using sentinels really just sees
that the animal is shedding infectious
amounts of material but then you have to
wait for the sentinel to get infected
and maybe produce antibodies so it's
much quicker if you can take them
directly from incoming animals that's a
great thing to use during quarantine
it's faster and it's also more sensitive
because pcr can detect sub-infectious
levels of shedding
i personally don't think intermittent
shedding is a problem
but if animals do intermittently shed
you would think that they would
sometimes shed sub-infectious amounts
you know it wouldn't be just all
infectious or none we do find animals
that are shedding sub-infectious amounts
at times
so we've been using pcr for a long time
pcr is an old story and we've been using
it to screen for helicobacter and then
we've started using it to uh as a
supplement for definitive identification
of some bacteria we use it primarily for
pastoral and metropolika streptobacillus
crying bacterium vulvas
normally microplasma pulmonous cultures
would need to go for two weeks
we can do pcr faster than that and with
more sensitivity so we use pcr instead
of the two-week culture for that
we use it for campylobacter and other
things that would
be difficult to culture
clostridium pilforming for tissues
disease would be another example so
we've been developing more and more
assays and we've also used it as a
confirmatory test for
viral infections primarily using
mesenteric lymph node or mln as a sample
and that's because mesenteric lymph node
saves little bits of dna from
things that get sampled in the intestine
so mesenteric lymph nodes kind of acts
like a little archive
saving bits of dna and antigen
that goes through the through the
intestinal tract
so as we've developed more and more pcr
assays
and getting lots of samples through the
lab which is a good thing
we've uh the large number of samples and
assays has really encouraged
miniaturization and automation because
we've needed to increase throughput so
how can we increase throughput
well
one way would be if we multiplexed pcr
in other words ran multiple pcr uh
reactions in the same vessel at the same
time
i mean certainly that would save
reagents materials and labor costs and i
think some diagnostic labs do it but the
problem
is that if you have one agent
present and high copy number it can mask
the presence of others
one can kind of hide the others and
very commonly helicobacter will be
present in high copy number we know
that's very common
parvo virus is also quite common but can
be present in low copy number and that's
what's illustrated on this slide you can
see that the
the top row of bands on this gel
is
mpv
that was added as 100 copies to this
assay
the bottom row of bands
is helicobacter
and you can see that as the helicobacter
concentration increases going towards
the left
from
10 to the zero which is 1 to 10 to 100
up to a hundred thousand on the far left
you can no longer see that the carbo
virus mpv seems to disappear even though
it's still present in the same
concentration so the high concentration
of helicobacter mask the mpv at high
concentration
and
we do frequently as you will see in
later slides find helicobacter in the 10
to the 4 to 10 to the 5 range so it
makes it hard to find helicobacter or
to find the mpv we do not think
multiplexing is a good idea
so what do we do we miniaturize the
assays and ruin them on an open array
platform to avoid multiplexing and this
is what we use
on the left
you can see that there is a uh
just sort of draw it here is a size of a
microscope slide
with many wells there are
uh
48 of these uh sub arrays each subarray
has 64 holes in it each hole is actually
only 33 nanoliters a total reaction
volume but that's aspirated into it it's
a hydrophobic outside hydrophilic inside
to hold the 33 nanoliters within it
but this means that each well is one
assay
so we don't have to multiplex whatever
is present in one does not interfere
with what's present in the next so that
avoids the problems of multiplexing and
it also gives us lots of wells to run a
lot of assays and a lot of controls
so when it's loaded onto the slide it
looks like this you can see that the
the top one has the samples loaded in
and on the bottom one you can see the
fluorescence that shows when we get
positive reactions
here on the on the right you can see
this is these are the tracings that we
get for each uh of the reaction so cycle
number goes across on the bottom
as cycle number increases
we get more and more fluorescence and
when it hits the threshold we call that
the ct value or the cycle
the threshold for
anyway the number of replications it
took before the fluorescence hit
threshold and that allows us to estimate
how many copies of the target agent are
present and that'll that gives us more
than just a plus minus it allows us to
understand what is really going on
so
our panels
we developed some fairly extensive
panels
these are some of the viruses that are
included we have panels that are just
mouse just rat we have panels that are
just even more viruses than this
many different
parasites pneumocystis a variety of
of protozoa
pen worms fermites
controls go on to each one we use the
nucleic acid recovery control because we
want to be sure that we're able to get
enough nucleic acid out of the sample
to make it a valid test and then we also
think it's really important to use the
pcr spike inhibition assay
to be sure that there isn't anything
present in the sample which is
inhibiting the pcr reaction and that
happens sometimes
with when you're testing feces when
you're testing material that may have
alginate presence in it
um
sometimes a really large amount of host
dna even can inhibit that somewhat so
those are very important controls to
include with each assay they're all run
in duplicate
and we also run a lot of bacteria and
then we do have other agents so we have
panels that would include acromiglia
sendai rio pneumonia virus etc
so remember this slide looking at the
limitations of soil bedding sentinels
we still haven't shown how we can go
back and fix this
we've talked about that there are
problems soil bedding sentinels don't
work great
we seem to have some pretty
sophisticated tools to work with
but how can we use these innovations in
pcr serology to actually improve the
programs okay keep in mind what each
test tells you serology you're saying
does the animal have antibodies in other
words was it infected sometime before
last week
serology is retrospective
pcr is just asking is a certain small
piece of dna or rna present it doesn't
necessarily mean it's infectious
it just means is it present
those tend to disappear from an animal
when they produce antibodies
so they the antibody response or immune
response will usually clear the virus so
it'll disappear from the feces but
dna and rna can stay in the lymph nodes
and can persist in a contaminated
environment so if it gets shed in the
dander or fecal dust or whatever it will
stay in the environment so pcr can
either be current by checking the feces
or retrospective by looking at
mesenteric lymph nodes or dust and
really should point out mesenteric lymph
nodes will become positive usually
within a couple days after infection
dust can become positive within a week
or so and both of those will stay
positive for a very long period of time
so what do we do with this how can we
how can we actually get a better picture
for what is happening in the rack
currently
well you could do the routine sentinel
serology plus some pcr
because pcr is so sensitive you can pool
10 fecal pellets into one sample so you
could take from the sentinel
and from animals on the rack they'd be
representing different breeding lines or
different experiments
you could even pull between racks
to manage the cost so that'll give you a
little better coverage
but still doesn't really give a 100
coverage
and that's where we get to the exhaust
plenums or the filters
these are concentration points for dust
and dander in the air system the air
exhaust system within the racks
so
we think of that as a type of
environmental monitoring and that's not
a new idea either
people have been looking at exhaust
ducts or surfaces for pathogens we've
done it on barrier rooms
for quite a while now
we've done it after decontamination to
verify a cleaning process people have
swept up dust and
used that
to monitor
sue compton and others at yale a number
of years ago actually piped the
exhaust on ivc racking through a
sentinel cage and monitored that and
found that it could contribute
and then more recently people have
actually started doing more targeted pcr
on the plenum dust eric johnson reported
last january 2013
that even a single cage
on iraq with a firmite infestation could
be detected within weeks on an otherwise
completely clean rack
just by testing the dust in the
horizontal planets
so it can be a sensitive and relatively
rapid
way to detect what's on on a rack
and these are some pictures from
from dr jensen
think
i forget what exactly which rack
manufacturer these were and i
don't want to guess wrong but
so we'll just leave that but you can see
that
he is uh sampling
in the uh
in the exhaust plenum
just take that we like using these
sticky swabs we like using sticky sauce
we will send those out to anybody who
wants them we find that using the
the
optimal swabs can give a tenfold
difference in signal strength so you it
makes a difference what swabs you use
and then obviously you need to use a
swab that the
your diagnostic lab can then retrieve
the nucleic acid from
so current evidence suggests as eric and
others have found that it's very
sensitive for mites and pen worms
very good strong signals for
helicobacter pasteurella spironucleus
get good signals for for parvovirus
norovirus rotavirus
lots of different bacteria caroni
bacterium vulvas cryptosporidium
pneumocystis
really it seems to be working very well
for a really wide range of pathogens
here is one example this rack had been
in use for about a year
we started looking because somebody
wanted us to look for uh parvo virus
actually in the plenum dust and so we
checked the plenum of uh
dust for different rows
and you can see that we did find uh
parvo virus
but since we were running it on a panel
that had other agents we went ahead and
ran it for for a lot of different agents
uh
i would like to take a look here at the
uh the number of
copies that we were finding for
helicobacter this is a hundred thousand
copies ten to the five this is the level
where
100 copies of parvo virus could be
inhibited might disappear if we were
doing multiplexing so if you're doing
multiplexing you might not have found
these if you were if you also were
checking for helicobacter at the same
time
and now these lines and the red lines
indicate uh agents i think that were a
surprise to the people doing the racks
things that were not being picked up by
their soiled bedding sentinels it's very
rare that pastrella pneumotropica gets
picked up by soil bedding sentinels
even though they're they're
you know readily detected by
pcr on the on the plenums
this is a real extreme example uh
instead of taking it from the
exhaust plenum from an individual rack
we went to the the cage wash area the
bedding dump station for a centralized
cage wash for the entire facility and i
think they had dogs and monkeys and
different things in the facility so it
wasn't just mice but just by sampling
the dust at the
dump station we all look at everything
that we found here the
the ones in again underlined in red are
things that are not likely to be picked
up by the soil bedding sentinels but you
can see also probably from some of those
other species we were even able to pick
up things like salmonella
etc so really you can find just about
anything that's present in the in the
soiled bedding
so remember this slide you probably
guess where i'm going with this soil
between sentinels are pretty poor at
picking up a lot of the common
infections but we find that they are
very readily detected
by rack swabs of the plenum dust on the
types of racks
where the dust will accumulate in those
in those plenums
so where are we now
keep in mind that not all racks are the
same they're not all equal
they may work all equally well as far as
i know for uh containing infection there
keeping it from spreading cage to cage
but not as far as the plenum sampling
goes
some of them have filtering on the
exhaust at the cage level and in those
cases you don't find much dust in the
exhaust system so that really makes a
difference
you have to look at your individual rack
and see where the dust is accumulating
if it's the filter or the pre-filter
take the samples there
you have to look where the dust is
accumulating or as we say dust is a must
if you do have an infection and you're
trying to clean up from that
you know then
perhaps residual nucleic acid could be
an issue it's probably good to do some
baseline testing in those cases but
that's only after contamination and
we're not really finding that to be much
of a problem
also
for all agents at this point what's the
minimum if something was in only one
cage
at a low level
you know how sure are we that it would
be picked up well
everything we see it seems to be that it
still works better than the bedding
subtitles so whether or not it's perfect
it seems to be better than betting
sentiments
conclusions at this time it really seems
to be the best sample there is and
completely sufficient for testing racks
for mites and pen words if the dust is
accumulating uh definitely better for
sentinels and better than sentinels for
helicobacter pastoral and pneumotropica
probably or possibly better than
norovirus
also when we get looking at those we
find a fair amount of
mouse adenovirus
cryptosporidium things that really were
surprises that we didn't realize were
common
so
at this point it's uh you know we're
really finding a lot of uh but it's very
good it's as good or betting better than
betting sentinels for all agents uh
that we've come across so far
when we actually put animals from a pet
shop into iraq just to see what we could
find we've even found positives for
sendai which we don't think would ever
get to a
into a soil bedding sentinel so today we
have found
no agent nothing that's detected better
by soil bedding sentinels than by
the exhaust air dust exhaust air dust
seems to be as good at or better than
bedding sentinels for everything so far
somebody asked if
if you have everything in open top
caging how good would the
exhaust for the entire room be
and we've looked at that with our
barrier rooms and found that it is still
a sensitive way of monitoring
those barrier rooms but our barrier
rooms might have ten thousand cages
and uh more than a hundred thousand
animals with a lot of breeding going on
so if you only have a small number of
cages
it's hard to really say if that's uh
sufficiently specific
however
and even in those cases if you're
submitting anything for pcr i would
include a swab of the dust of those
exhaust vents as a supplemental sample
if you send it to us we could take
we can pull a lot of different samples
into one assay so one price right one
assay you would you could send us 10
swabs 10 fecal pellets we would extract
the nucleic acid from those separately
we'd like you to send them in separate
containers but then we would pool that
together for the assay and so
if i was doing it i would include the
swabs of the of the exhaust
grates
so
additional considerations some things
just aren't shed in the feces such as uh
lactate dehydrogenase elevating virus
most cytomegalovirus you know those
things we really wouldn't expect to show
up but they're not going to show up and
soil that in sentinels either and so you
know if you're concerned about those
maybe you could do some survival bleeds
with the easy spot
and uh
you know might be able to pick it up
that way also
yeah it may not be applicable to all
rack systems you'd have to take a look
at
you know your own racks see where the
dust is accumulating
you know different manufacturers are
taking a look at this now
they seem convinced that it's a good way
of sampling they they sort of sense the
shift in the field
and are looking at adapting rack design
to exhaust air dust sampling and and
really
the confidence and the results depends
on you have to have confidence in your
life you know you need to be sure that
they're using quantitative methods have
confidence in the sensitivity of their
assays controls and all so it it's
you have to have confidence in your lab
in order to go forward with it
sometimes we can find trace dna
without infections doesn't happen often
happens once in a while could be
cross-contamination of samples i mean
on the sampling end you'd have to be
sure to keep
to not get any cross-contamination
between samples
we go to great lengths to try to
separate on our end but you know it's
always theoretically possible could
happen
we have seen instances where it seems
there is non-infectious dna present in
feed or other bulk materials you know
there could be dna present without it
being evidence of infection
and you know if you had a past
contamination you would wonder could it
be uh residual dna from past
contaminations that way
so uh
you would need to go back that way
always call your lab regarding any
unexpected or anomalous results right if
you don't think you have pastoral
pneumotropica you get a positive for it
or for parbovirus or whatever before you
take action call your lab and discuss it
one of the beauties of tacman pcr is
that it is semi-quantitative so
if you talk to us we can often help work
out whether it's likely to be consistent
with an active infection or not
helicobacter i keep saying is present in
high copy number if we got just a trace
amount of it on a on us on a sample that
you sent us
it would be more likely to be a
cross-contamination somehow than an
active infection so we'll work with you
on that in some diagnostic labs
i know we will and i would hope others
would will perform some additional
testing at no charge to follow up on the
initial positive so we wouldn't leave
you hanging we got to help you work out
in those cases so if you get an
anomalous or an unexpected result call
the lab
one thing i don't have here but but i
always try to remind people is if you're
using a diagnostic lab you're already
paying for their experts right you're
already paying their salaries so if
you're using them give them a call and
ask questions you know don't ever
hesitate to ask them they also know
what's what's happening maybe there's a
nationwide outbreak of rotavirus
if so they could that would be some
additional perspective on your results
that it might be useful to know so
always call your lab
and so taking all of this
can the shipping of live animals for
routine surveillance be replaced by just
shipping serum or pcr samples
and and obviously i think the answer is
yes or wouldn't be presenting this but
it's yes if
the mice are being tested to see if they
meet specifications you know a defined
exclusion list so
if you're testing them to see if they
have any of a list of 20 agents
we or other diagnostic labs can could
develop tests or probably have them
already to
test for those agents and
for almost all of them all of them as
far as i know
testing you don't need to submit live
animals but it's not a vague phenotyping
kind of thing it's do the animals have
one of these list of agents
so shipping live animals is expensive
i'm sure the listeners here know that
much better than i do shipping one crate
can be hundreds of dollars
more than the cost of the testing there
are weather embargoes i mean
much of the country right now is colder
than 20 fahrenheit and much of the rest
of the air a lot of it is warmer than 85
so there are weather embargoes to
shipping and
the microbial status can even change
during shift shipping so have to keep
that in mind animals can die if they're
sick
but but don't hesitate to send dead
animals or don't worry too much
it's a welfare issue if they die they're
in shipping but you can still sometimes
get some valuable pathology results from
it so
you know if an abscess or tumor is there
you can still see it even if the animal
is pretty rotten so don't
don't throw away animals just because
they're they're dead but but there is
animal welfare issues with shipping and
so it's better not to ship only when you
have to the default shipment should be
serum feces or other specimens
um live animals
you know when would they have advantages
well
some people find it easier just to put
animals into a crate ship them to the
lab than to take all the samples
themselves
but i think if you're collecting serum
easy spot is probably easier than even
putting them into the crate dust swabs
are easy
shipping them uses the expertise of the
diagnostic lab more fully so if it's
some sort of tricky diagnostic situation
it may make sense to send live animals
so that the diagnostic experts can
really take a look at it and and
sometimes if you're trying to culture
for anaerobes it's easier to do it
by culture
we do have
we're developing pcr there is pcr for
tricomone ads now but
if you're just sending feces for
parasitology remember that some protozoa
don't form cysts
so we've pretty well covered this uh so
what would you ship if you're shipping
live mites obviously ship the live mice
but if you want to ship samples instead
of animals
you could ship serum or the easy spot
and charles river or other diagnostic
labs i'm sure but you know we'll send
you the shipping materials we'll send
you
instructions on how to sell them out how
to complete it what to do walk you
through it we've got online support for
that
presumably other diagnostic labs would
also
so if you're shipping samples
you could just ship serum and a fecal
pellet and really that covers just about
everything
if
it probably wouldn't cover furmites so
if you're looking for fur mites probably
would want to include a fur swab or
sometimes we call it a body swab
remember that samples for pcr can be
pulled from up to 10 animals
so if you're going to send a pellet from
one animal you might as well collect a
pellet from nine others and send it it
doesn't hurt the sensitivity and it
gives you a little broader broader
screening so if you can pool ten to one
i would say you should always pull ten
to one and remember that long
in another envelope but but as part of
the same uh diagnostic test panel we
could include ten swabs so you might as
well send ten swabs at the same time
or instead of sending those you could
send pooled exhaust air duct swabs
and maybe some cooled fecal pellets
or really pretty much you could find
about anything you wanted with just
those exhaust air duct swabs without the
serum or or first watch for anything you
would use fur swabs for the plenum swabs
or the exhaust air dust swabs are better
so so uh fur swabs early are not as
necessary as they used to be the dust
swabs are a beautiful replacement for
those
so just to conclude and then we'll get
on to some of the questions and
hopefully that'll stimulate even more uh
discussion
and
you know we're continuing to discover
additional uh subclinical infections uh
as our tests improve we find more and
more i don't think any of them are
really new i think they've all been
around forever we're just finding them
but uh
it's important to know what's there
advances in diagnostic methods now make
it possible to test whether or not your
in-house animals are within
specifications without the need to
routinely ship any live animals for
health surveillance
remember diagnostics investigations you
know if you have sick animals you have
an outbreak anomalous research results
diagnostic investigations may still
benefit from submission of live animals
to your diagnostic lab
and the easy spot serology
and exhaust air dust pcr can reduce or
replace much of the sentinel usage
so
i think i'll get onto the questions just
like to point out this is where i live
right about
here in the
willamette valley actually gets about
over here beautiful wine country and
this is mount hood as we can
see from near here
so thank you for your attention
the questions are um
let's see uh
i believe we talked about the room's
hepa exhaust
the answer is yes
although we don't really know the full
sensitivity on it
information on the type of swab needed
we will send those free of charge just
contact charles river
it's
crl.com you can just look up our website
and go to the diagnostic testings
testing website people will help you on
that
how long does the dust sample remain
viable and how far back can the testing
reach
that's a good question
the
dust sample of course isn't isn't truly
viable
what we're looking for is
genetic or dna length that are long
enough sequences that are long enough
for our pcr and tacman uses really short
sequences they should stay
present it would be years probably
before they would degrade
potentially
they could sort of wash out with the
continued air flow
over a period of months but within
quarterly monitoring we have not seen
that be a problem
we haven't really tracked out low level
uh
contaminations within iraq and then
followed them for a year or so to see
how long they would go but certainly
within a quarterly uh probably even
within six months monitoring we haven't
seen a haven't seen a problem um
next question is we may get some wild
caught kangaroo rats of course i think
that would be uh pretty interesting
uh
and we need to check those for urine
viruses
can we use normal rat panels or do we
need to have the rattus species
sentinels and teslas i think those are
two separate questions
one would be
what
infections do the kangaroo rats have
that could infect them or
affect them and the second question is
do they have anything that could infect
rats elsewhere in the facility the true
rattus norvegicus
and so
i think it'd be better to have the
offline discussion on that sometimes it
would be useful to use rat sentinels
which could give a good answer as to
whether the kangaroo rats have anything
which theoretically could transfer to
rats
and then we would typically use some
targeted pcr for zoonotic agents to
screen the the kangaroo rats we also
could do serology
using a
g protein
instead of a secondary antibody to look
for sort of entire groups of viruses
like generic parabol viruses generic
coronaviruses rotaviruses etc but you
can see that gets a little technical so
crl.com or ask crl and we could get into
more detail on that
um
quality
let's see wouldn't it be much cheaper to
send the animals for the health
monitoring plus than to do all the
individual tests as of the serum sequels
etc that's a that's a good question
because
i wouldn't even advise doing this if it
raised your health monitoring costs and
but here's how that goes health
monitoring on one animal
costs about one and a half times a full
serology panel
and
full pcr panel costs about one and a
half times what the
a live animal submission would be
so the full pcr panel would be about one
and a half times as much
as a uh as a live animal submission
but you could check 10 animals
and what would you submit for the single
animal would it be a sentinel if you
submit a sentinel we know that there are
real disadvantages to that you'd be
better off running
a serala you would be better off running
a pcr panel on swabs from two racks
pooled would be less than doing two live
animal sentinels and you would get more
information
so you got to look at your own you know
your own systems it may not be right for
all situations but it's not necessarily
more expensive i mean i think that's a
it's a good question you have to look at
um
frequency of survey testing uh for uh
you know most often used in rats or mice
i think most people are looking
quarterly some places look every six
months there's really nothing magic
about it
if some people use three and some people
use six i've heard of others using four
months
there's really no magic number i'd say
the most common is quarterly falaza in
europe recommends quarterly
but there is no
we check our own colonies every two
weeks one way or another but but it's a
different situation there is no magic
answer
soil betting sentinels get a little less
susceptible to infection after three
months or so so you may be a little less
likely to pick up rotavirus or some
others
although there's controversy on that
some people think even that doesn't
matter so
just no magic answer sorry
let's see
some labs may still need import export
health certification certification to
ship samples across international
borders that's true
i think in those cases what we usually
will read the rest of it in northern
ireland i had to set up rodent samples
only lab referral because the available
airlines wouldn't ship live animals
anyway yeah that's a factor shipping
live animals can be a real problem in
many cases
it's often much easier to ship samples
we can arrange to receive pcr samples
that have been
inactivated by one means or another or
serum samples that have been so it may
be easier to
to shift those
sometimes the question comes up about
for international shipping
certain long lists of agents may be
required but i think usually you're
better off only testing
the animals destined or considered for
shipping for that
really long list rather than your entire
facility all the time but of course you
know you have to resolve that for your
own facility
question is that the cost of health
certification shipping of live animals
can be prohibited absolutely it's
illegal to ship animals likely to give
birth and sucklings in the uk i think
that's uh
that's uh um
well that's fact probably but it's but
it also makes sense to me so if you want
to monitor uh samples from those then
it's best to ship the samples and so
that may be the only
method available in some cases but i
think for all if you're looking against
this
set list of agents
the
testing is at least as sensitive
as
shipping live animals anyway so you're
really not giving up any
you know any testing sensitivity
question ask your state veterinary
service about the licensing particularly
if you want to send live placental
mammals to australia
and um
yes
i would always recommend before shipping
any animals
of any kind
anywhere to be absolutely sure that
you're doing it within
the regulatory guidance you know it's
the la that's the last thing anybody
would want to be to be caught with and
in some situations
the same thing for
samples from uh living animals so
um
you know samples collected from animals
sometimes societies permits or whatever
are required so everybody needs to be
careful about that
question is can we do an assessment plus
with the easy spot and the answer is yes
so we can do any of the any of the
assays
with the easy spot for our which is our
name for the the dried blood spot
systems
so um
any other questions at this time
there was one question which which i
dodged admittedly on which uh
qa or iso program do we subscribe to
and i don't have an answer
for that i i don't know the answer for
it
but if you contact me offline
it's charles.clifford
crl.com
charles.clifford.crl.com
we can find you an answer
so thank you very much everybody
so no more questions we can close
thank you very much